[Music]
in the lobby and there's a parked
self-driving car and there are drones
hanging from the Raptors it looks like a
museum of alternative future employees
around 180 000 people worldwide making
it one of the biggest Employers in the
tech industry I'm sure you're all
familiar with Google's moonshot Factory
it's the home of Google's most ambitious
projects from Google Glass and waymo to
Loon and verily even before the moonshot
factory was formerly founded in 2010
Google was at the Forefront of
technological development and
advancement but it appears that this has
been changing over the past couple of
years like any Corporation Google has
become more focused on profits and
pleasing shareholders than making
massive bets we no longer see those
over-the-top presentations from Sergey
Brin and Larry Page nor do we hear about
Google making money tangible progress
with self-driving this trend has simply
been exacerbated by the recession in
September Google canceled up to half of
their r d projects across the company
and more recently it was reported that
Google is diverting much of its moonshot
Factory efforts into Revenue generating
projects
Trend doesn't just apply to Google's
moonshot Factory either it's actually a
larger Trend that can be observed across
the company many Google veterans have
raised concerns that Google's culture
has become unrecognizable and the recent
layoffs are just one example of that the
old Google would have done anything to
prevent layoffs similar to Southwest if
you didn't know Southwest has never done
layoffs despite facing way more to much
less times than Google from the 1973 oil
crisis in 2001 to 2008 and the pandemic
meanwhile Google is posting near record
profits and the toaster lay off 12 000
people mostly due to shareholder
concerns but likely the best example of
Google turning the corner is the fact
that they dropped their famous slogan
don't be evil in 2015 Google added a new
model to their code of conduct do the
right thing before dropping the original
slogan in 2018
this massive shift didn't just happen
overnight though so here's the slow
Devolution of a Google from being the
ambitious startup that was at the
Forefront of tech to being the
background company that just wants to
stay in their Lane
when you think about a career at Google
one of the first things that come to
mind are the high compensation Prestige
and influence for decades Google has
prided themselves with paying the
absolute highest salaries and from a
statistical standpoint this is still
very much true in 2021 alphabet once
again topped the median employee salary
list coming in with the median
compensation of 295 thousand dollars
combine this with the insane perks that
Google offers like their free food and
remote working opportunities and you
would think that Google employees are
living the High Life objectively
speaking they are but happiness is very
much a relative thing and for people
working at Google all of these perks are
very much the norm not to mention Google
is no longer the only company where you
can enjoy these benefits until recently
the number of options that these people
had was unprecedented leading them to
feel unsatisfied and yes under
compensated I know that's probably hard
to believe so I've got survey results to
back this up back in early 2022 Business
Insider found that only a mere 46
percent of surveyed Google employees
were happy with their compensation in
other words over half of Google's
Workforce thinks that their compensation
isn't competitive and this feeling is
simply getting stronger every single
year back in 2020 64 of Google's
employees felt that their compensation
was competitive this number dropped to
56 in 2021 before dropping to 46 percent
much of this can be explained by even
stronger offers coming from startups
like coinbase and stripe but it's not
just the compensation that googlers are
upset with many also feel that the
company is becoming more bureaucratic
and less transparent within the cloud
division for example only 54 of
employees feel that the promotional
process is fair you can decipher this in
two ways either you can think that these
guys are simply spoiled brats who don't
realize how good they have it or you can
think that these guys truly do have a
lot more potential like becoming a
founder or an executive either way
though the end of feeling is the same
unhappy and unmotivated employees and
this feeling only leads to two things
High attrition and or a stagnant
Workforce the high attrition is no
secret at alphabet the median tenure is
only a mere 1.3 years this statistic is
skewed by new hires but that doesn't
really make the statistic of all that
much better speaking of new hires Google
has been aggressively recruiting and
growing their Workforce over the past 10
years between 2009 and 2021 Google's
Workforce Grew From 20 000 employees to
156 000 employees and realistically
speaking it's nearly impossible to
maintain the same culture and caliber
across 156 000 people it's more than
likely that as a potential portion of
these new hires were simply looking for
the compensation and a resume boost and
when you have too many of these people
it's just a matter of time onto your
company becomes soulless
and it's common for Founders to have a
bunch of beef with shareholders Mark
Zuckerberg for example is actively
fighting the entire world when it comes
to pursuing the metaverse this was very
much the same case with Google's
Founders Larry Page and Sergey Brin and
this Strife between investors and
Executives is very much what gave Google
its unique culture in 2001 for example
Larry Page went ahead and fired up all
of Google's Project managers the
reasoning well Paige felt that Engineers
didn't need anyone to give them
directions and that they shouldn't be
forced to follow arbitrary deadlines HR
did end up reversing this decision but
this gives us a glimpse of just how
Paige felt about managers and why Google
ended up being such an engineering
driven company similarly Sergey felt
that no one should be 200 feet away from
food and this is why Google has so much
food everywhere despite it being rather
uneconomical many of Google's most
iconic moves were actually such
unorthodox Rebel earliest actions both
Paige and Brynn have a history of
completing Acquisitions without
consulting anyone else in the company
including even the official CEO this was
the case with even Android and Google
Earth we should also note that this
approach has led to a bunch of failures
like Google Glass but the takeaway isn't
that the founders were rebellious the
takeaway is that the founders didn't
care about the bureaucracy or angry
shareholders their main goal was simply
doing the best thing for the company
this is the main reason that both
Founders actually left Google they felt
that they could no longer do what was
right for the company and at that there
was simply too much red tape to keep
fighting conversely Google's new
leadership isn't put off by the red tape
in fact you could even argue that they
liked the red tape as it gives them
purpose definition meaning their jobs as
Executives is to make shareholders happy
and to constantly grow earnings quarter
after quarter and from this perspective
Sundar piche has headed out of the park
since he became CEO in 2015 Google stock
has grown as much as 5x and even with
the recession Google is up Forex
a similar story can be seen with
Google's fundamentals as well since 2015
Google's revenue has grown from 70
billion to 280 billion and their net
income has grown from 15 billion to over
70 billion so clearly Sunder has given
shareholders exactly what they wanted it
but this very much came with a cost to
accomplish such growth Google couldn't
focus on random out there projects that
were very much a Gamble
instead it Google had to double down on
their revenue generating sector such as
ads and their cloud and focus on making
these Endeavors as profitable as
possible and that's exactly what they
did they cut out all the fluff but while
this seemed like fluff for shareholders
this is what made it Google Google and
without it Google became just another
Solace Tech Corporation
[Applause]
while much of the new Google has to do
with the shift in leadership and
employee culture not all of it can be
attributed to Google themselves much of
the old Google was formed by public
sentiment and much of the new Google is
also formed by public sentiment in fact
you could argue that Google's public
sentiment was what made them so
successful in the first place take Gmail
for example much of Gmail's appeal came
from the fact that it was exclusive and
generous storage and was anti-yahuwah
and Microsoft the same thing could be
said about chroma much of Chrome's
appeal came from the fact that it was
fast reliable and anti-internet Explorer
and Microsoft Google had built this
image as the White Knight savior tech
company that wasn't evil but the
sentiment around Google has shifted
substantially over the past 15 years
Google is no longer the startup taking
on bigger players Google is the big
player not to mention it Google has also
built up a rather negative reputation
when it comes to data election and
privacy we've all seen those memes that
Alexa Google and Syria are always
listening this sentiment hurts the
company in two ways for one the public
is less likely to support new products
that come from the company a great
example of this is with Google fi their
cell phone plan objectively speaking
Google fi offers extremely generous
plans that come in way cheaper than the
competition this is the same formula
that Google used with the Gmail and
Google Fiber took great success but most
people don't even know about Google 5
because the cellular space already had
an anti-carrier player T-Mobile if
anything Google was viewed more like
atnt and Verizon than they were as
T-Mobile and this makes sense because
Google was essentially trying to control
your smartphone your OS the things that
you do on your phone and your connection
if the public isn't even willing to
support a cell phone plan then it's much
less likely that they'll support
something that's truly out there
just take a look at Facebook sure my
metaverse is underwhelming but I'd bet
that much of its criticism comes from
people's already negative opinion of
Facebook the metaverse wouldn't be
nearly as ridiculed if it wasn't
associated with Facebook and Mark
Zuckerberg for obvious reasons Google
does not want to go down the same path
so they've decided to Simply play it on
the safe side aside from the public not
being receptive to new products negative
stigma also makes it much more difficult
to attract the best talent Google is not
the top company that engineering
students want to work for the top
companies that engineering students want
to work for are SpaceX and Tesla and
those companies don't even pay crazy
salaries or offer ridiculous perks as
more and more talented Engineers flock
to such companies and startups it's no
wonder why Google is no longer pushing
the boundaries
foreign
Google was iconic for setting outrageous
goals and going all in it regardless of
how ridiculous it makes them look or the
odds of success but ever since Larry and
Sergey left Google has become much more
timeout mostly due to complacent
employees a priority to please
shareholders and a rapidly deteriorating
Public Image given that Google's revenue
and the net income was going faster than
they can count for the past several
years Google didn't have any problems
keeping some of their projects alive but
now that Google can feel the pressure on
their bottom line Google is Shifting to
take decisive action this isn't to say
that Google will be screwed or that this
move will backfire in fact I'm sure that
this move will work out great
financially but at the same time this is
just another example of Google taking
yet another step closer to becoming a
Cisco or an Intel and that's truly quite
a shame are you a fan of the new Google
comment that down below also drop a like
if you missed the order Google and of
course consider checking out our Discord
Community such as for 3D ideas and
consider subscribing to see more
questions logically answered but until
then I'm Hari Nazi guys on the next one